-Paula, we've been friends
for a long time,
and I always love
having you on the show.
-I love it.
-You did one bit when we were on
the Zoom shows, and thank you
for being a guest,
where you fake froze
on the screen.
-Yep.
-And, honestly, I didn't see it
done before, and I take all
of your bits, and I do them.
I try to give you credit
for all the time I take them.
-And I'm sure you do them
better than me.
-No, I do not.
But can you show everyone
what it's like to do a freeze.
-Yeah.
-Like, what camera
would be best?
-This one here, camera one.
-This -- one?
Okay.
-Here we go.
How was --
How was your spring?
Any summer --
-It was good, Jimmy.
I mean, you know, we're
in quarantine and everything,
but I've been
trying to learn guitar,
and I've been trying to do
a little more singing.
So, I --
Oh, I --
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughing ]
That's exactly --
That's exactly right.
That's how you do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is how you do it.
That is a pro.
Thank you for doing that.
How many bits have we done
together through out the years?
-We have done so many bits.
And you know, we used to do bits
on "SNL" because we didn't know
what we were going to write.
Or we were writing something
that was not going well.
-Do you remember the one where
we used to do a bit
where we'd say something --
we'd get fake mad at each other,
and say the worst thing
you could ever say to someone,
and then we would leave
and slam the door.
And then you have to sheepishly
come back in, and get your keys.
-Yeah, I'm gonna show you
right now.
You've all done it when you've
had a fight with your spouse
or a family member.
You really have a good exit.
You really, really
leave on a good note of, like,
"You're dead to me,"
and then you have
to come back in for something.
So, here it is.
-All right. So what are --
-You know what, Jimmy?
I'm really sick of your
pretty-boy, charm box
bull crap, okay?
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-No, I'm sick of it.
I have -- I've --
I've put on a fake smile
all these years with you,
and I am done!
I am done with you!
I'm -- I'm outta here!
I'm outta here!
-Okay.
-All right?
-Gosh.
-Is this the exit?
[ Laughter ]
I'm done!
I don't ever
want to see you again.
-Okay.
That was weird.
[ Light laughter ]
-I forgot my phone.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you forgot your phone.
Yeah.
-In this time that I was gone,
I thought about things.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm sorry.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, okay.
-I -- I'm --
I'm sorry.
I've had three coffees.
I'm a little constipated.
I am jacked up.
I'm sorry that I went there.
Okay? I'm sorry.
I forgive you.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Forgive me?
-Yeah.
-Forgive me?
I should forgive you!
-Yeah, oh, for -- yeah.
Oh, yeah!
Forgive you for being
the biggest loser that's ever
been on my show, ever!
-That's spit!
-Yeah, it is spit!
I spit right there.
And guess what!
You're husband's
cheating on you, you idiot!
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
-Well, tell my
lesbian wife that!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hi.
-I, uh...
I just forgot
I have to finish --
finish hosting the show.
[ Laughter ]
And I had some time
to think about what I said.
That was silly of me,
and I was out of line.
I don't know
what I even was saying.
And, uh...
I forgive you.
-I forgive you.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-And scene.
And that's a scene.
[ Laughing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Tell my --
Tell my lesbian wife that."
-"Tell my lesbian wife that!"
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, Mom.
It's the first
she's heard of it.
-Oh, wow!
[ Laughter ]
Paula, let's talk about --
-This is the good view for --
This is a good angle, right?
For talk shows?
[ Laughter ]
-Let's talk about "Girls5eva."
-Okay, let's talk about
"Girls5eva."
-"Girls5eva" -- it's on Peacock.
-Oh, it's such a fun show.
-It is a fun show.
It's a musical show.
Basically, it's a girl group
from the '90s that reunite.
-Yeah.
-And they are underdogs.
-Yep, we were a one-hit wonder,
and then a rapper
sampled one of our songs.
Probably the only hit
we ever had.
-Yeah.
-And so we're trying to --
You know,
we're really underdogs.
We're trying to get it back,
and we storm the stage
at the end of last season
at Jingle Ball.
And so we ended up
with a record deal,
which is very exciting.
So this season
is all about album mode.
We're making a record,
but it is with Property Records,
which is owned
by the Property Brothers.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-So it's a little low-end.
-No, but everyone's --
People are doing a lot things
these days.
-Yes.
-So the Property Brothers
have a record label.
-Yes, and it's not low-end
because of the Property Brothers
being low-end,
'cause they're fabulous, but --
I watch them all the time.
But they haven't
been in the music industry.
Music space, as they call it.
Is that what they call it,
The Roots? The space?
-Do they show up in the season?
Can we say?
-They show up some
in the season,
and we have
a lot of fun guest stars.
And there's a lot of
funny songs this season.
And there's also --
This summer before we shot,
I actually
had my knee replacement
that I got five years ago.
I got two knee replacements,
and one of them collapsed.
And so I had to get
another knee replacement.
So they wrote that
into the show.
So there's a whole element
at the beginning of the season
where I hurt my knee in a very
comedy way that you will enjoy.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Paula Pell in the new
season of "Girls5eva."
-And this is after I'm trying
to medicate my knee
when I first got it done,
but still trying
to keep our album mode
and our promotion.
-Very medicated, Paula Pell.
-My guests today
are mounting a comeback.
You may remember them as
the first women to wear thong,
thong thong, thong, thongs
to the White House.
Welcome, Girls5eva.
How you feeling today, ladies?
-Blessed.
-Great.
-Amazing.
-God-like.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Now, I hear you are about
to go back into the studio
to record your first album
since "2K01."
Now, is that accurate?
-Absolutely, Nathan.
We start next week,
and we're just super excited --
-I love New York.
I like to eat burgers
and look at the skyline.
-Yes, and we're hungry
to get back at it.
Right, ladies?
-Absolutely.
-Yum, Yum, jum jum.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Paula Pell, everybody!
The new season of "Girls5eva"
premiers May 5th on Peacock.